- [Instructor] As we've
discussed in other videos,
the federal bureaucracy is a
huge part of the US government,
sometimes even called the fourth branch.
It has more than two million employees
who work in various agencies
dedicated to implementing the law.
So the bureaucracy has a lot of discretion
to decide how best to
achieve a policy goal.
But the sheer size of the bureaucracy,
along with its independence,
can make it difficult to monitor.
What happens when a bureaucratic agency
fails to carry out its mission,
or deviates from the letter
or the intent of a law?
What can the other branches
do to keep it accountable?
Let's use a real example to
make things a bit more concrete.
In 2014, a whistleblower
came forward, reporting that
a hospital in the Department
of Veterans Affairs
was deceiving federal regulators
about how long veterans were
waiting to receive healthcare.
Because officials at
the VA got pay bonuses
based on ensuring that patients
had short wait times for medical care,
they were falsifying electronic records
to keep wait times within
those acceptable guidelines.
In reality though, the average
wait time for medical care
was greater than 100 days,
and dozens of veterans died
while waiting for delayed appointments.
Now, this is a pretty complex story,
so I'm just giving you
the broad strokes here.
But for our purposes,
what you need to know is
this was a case of very
serious mismanagement
in a bureaucratic agency.
So now, let's think about
what the other branches
of government could do,
using their formal and informal powers,
in response to this situation.
I encourage you to pause the video here,
and see if you can list
at least one action
that the executive branch, Congress,
or the judicial branch could take.
Ready, go.
Okay, so let's go through
some of the actions
that the other branches did take
in response to the VA scandal,
and you can check to see if
you came up with any of them.
So what steps did the executive take?
Remember that the bureaucracy itself
is under the executive branch.
So first, we saw internal investigations
from the Secretary of Veterans
Affairs, Eric Shinseki.
The VA used its rulemaking authority
to abandon the unrealistic wait time goal
in order to remove that
perverse incentive.
It was within the power of Barack Obama,
who was president at the time,
to fire the cabinet secretary,
but instead, Shinseki resigned.
Then the president used
his nomination power
to replace him with a new
VA secretary, Bob McDonald.
Obama also introduced a
number of executive actions
to address the problem,
including establishing an independent
accountability review board,
a board of physicians
to advise the secretary,
a plan to upgrade the
electronic health record system,
and protections for whistleblowers.
What steps did Congress take?
First, Congress used its
oversight power to call hearings,
investigating what was going on at the VA.
They subpoenaed Secretary
Shinseki to testify.
They also passed reform measures,
using their lawmaking powers
and the power of the purse
to fix the larger problems at the VA,
funding a $16 billion plan to
hire more doctors and nurses,
upgrade facilities, and allow veterans
to see private doctors if necessary.
And as part of this reform,
Congress included legislation
that made it easier
to hold VA officials
accountable for misconduct.
Congress also used its power
to approve presidential nominations
by confirming the new VA secretary.
The judicial branch, for its part,
reviewed the constitutionality
of the new rules
holding VA employees accountable.
The federal court system heard a case
about whether it was constitutional
to fire civil servants
who weren't appointed,
without giving them a chance to appeal.
The courts ruled that
that was unconstitutional,
so in 2017, Congress passed a new bill,
adding a grievance process
for civil servants,
which President Trump
then signed into law.
So it's been a few years
since the VA scandal,
so how are things doing?
Did the reform measures work?
In 2015, The New York Times reported
that only three people had been fired
as a response to the scandal,
despite Bob McDonald's public statements
that 60 employees had been fired.
In 2019, Debra Draper,
the healthcare director
at the Government Accountability Office,
told the House Veterans Affairs Committee
that although the VA had made progress
in wait times and scheduling,
there was still room for improvement.
She said that the VA's new system
was still not accurately
recording patient wait times,
and that veterans might still wait
up to 70 days for an appointment,
even though the VA was
reporting a much shorter delay.
On the positive side, the VA completed
one million more appointments for veterans
in 2018 than in 2017, showing that
access to care for veterans
had definitely improved.
So what do you think?
Were the other branches of government
able to hold the VA accountable?
If you had to solve this problem,
either as a member of Congress,
a judge, or the president,
what other steps could you take?